DAVID EDERY: Hello, everyone.
Let's see.
OK, so I'm going
to admit, this was
supposed to be a free-to-play
fundamentals talk.
But then the more
I worked on it,
the more I realized I wanted
to talk about misconceptions.
So it kind of turned into a
free-to-play misconceptions
talk.
I hope you're OK with that.
If you're not OK with that,
you can yell at me later.
So the first misconception I
wanted to talk about is-- oh,
and actually, you
guys may not know.
My company made "Triple Town,"
"Alphabear," "Bushido Bear."
We just released "Alphabear 2".
We made a game called
"Realm of the Mad God."
Those are all
free-to-play games.
Some of them reached
huge audiences.
Most of them did not
make all that much money.
We're trying to
get better at that.
I think we've finally gotten
a little bit better at that.
So anyway, OK, free-to-play
misconceptions.
So the first one is people
will donate to you if you just
ask nicely and take all
the free-to-play stuff out
of your game.
I hear this all the time.
It's a really common
misconception.
You'll hear it most particularly
from the vocal minority
in any game.
They'll just say ah,
if you would just
take out all this
free-to-play crap,
we would just give you money.
We actually tried this
many, many years ago.
Because we like to do
these kinds of experiments.
And it failed miserably.
We made basically, no money.
I know lots of other
indies have tried it.
Virtually all of them
have also failed.
There are like one-in-a-million
examples where they actually
make good money
taking donations.
And that ends up
fooling everybody.
Please don't do this.
Don't assume that
you can basically
do no work to make money
and just ask for donations
and you'll be fine.
People give donations
because they
see a picture of a starving
child in their Facebook feed,
or because their
friend has cancer.
Those are the things that
cause people to give donations.
They don't give donations to
you because your game is fun.
That almost never works,
so please don't do that.
The second misconception is
that any game can be profitable
if you simply sell
aesthetic items only,
which are items that
make you look good,
or show you dancing or
whatever, and not a functional
benefit in any way.
And that obviously, is
a misconception as well.
It depends on the game.
So in particular, it depends
if it's a multiplayer game.
Like if you have a
multiplayer game where there's
a lot of person-to-person
interaction,
people can see your character
doing certain things,
then yeah, it makes
perfect sense.
You can show off
for other people.
You can dress nicely
You can do a dance
move for other people,
so it makes sense to buy stuff.
When you're in a single-player
game where nobody can see you,
it doesn't really make sense
to spend a lot of money
on aesthetic items.
It can work.
I mean, these are all like
sort of general rules, right?
I'm sure there's an exception
that proves the rule somewhere.
But for the most part,
it's a really bad idea
to make a single-player
game and then
try to make all your money
selling aesthetic goods.
In general, even in
multiplayer games,
like in our upcoming
"Steambirds Alliance" game,
which is based on an MMO we made
called "Realm of the Mad God--"
that's a highly, highly
real-time multiplayer game.
In theory, we could make money
selling only aesthetic items.
But we also sell
functional ones that
are designed not
to make it easier
to win or to beat other
people, but just to make
your game playing
experience more convenient.
Like we'll sell
inventory storage
if you want to be a pack
rat and save more items.
You don't have to, but it
makes the game a little bit
more convenient and
a little bit more
fun if you can be a pack
rat and store more stuff.
So we sell you that.
And that sells really, really,
really well even though it's
not a pay-to-win item.
So in general, I highly
recommend not deciding
that you're just going to sell
aesthetic goods unless you
have a multiplayer game that
can really potentially support
that.
And even then, be aware
that for the most part,
the games that
make a lot of money
doing that tend to be these sort
of massive cultural phenomenons
like "League of Legends."
And in general, my
argument is if you're
betting that you're going to be
the next "League of Legends,"
maybe you have an
overconfidence problem.
That's kind of my way
of thinking about it.
So the next misconception--
that you can
divide gamers into
either they're hardcore
or they're casual.
I think this is nonsense.
And in fact, I think almost
every bucketing nowadays
is harmful.
Like I'm not a fan
of another bucket
of saying oh, people
in the United States
have different attitudes
about free-to-play
than people in China.
Like sometimes
yes, sometimes no.
It depends on the genre.
It depends on the target
group that you're targeting.
So no, in general, no
to all of this stuff.
And let me give you
a concrete example
of where this might break down.
If you look at the word
game audience, which
is something I'm very,
very familiar with,
you might say, oh OK, that's
clearly a casual audience,
right?
Like it's mostly
women, like a majority
of women who play
them, more adults
than kids, on and on and on.
That must be a casual audience.
Well, what are the stereotypes
we have about casual gamers?
They don't like
complicated games
and they don't like competition.
Totally wrong.
Scrabble in
particular, and "Words
With Friends," which is
the modern incarnation,
has basically trained
generations of word gamers
to lust for blood.
Like they want to
crush the competition.
It's amazing how
much they want it.
And so we make
single-player word games.
And we know for a fact that
it's hurting our retention.
We get feedback all the time
from people who are like,
I love this game,
but I would love
it so much more if you had
any sort of competition in it.
So right now we're working on
putting a tournament feature
into "Alphabear 2."
Because these people
want to compete,
including whatever
stereotype you
want to conjure up, the
50-year-old, 60-year-old
grandma who only plays Scrabble.
She likes beating people.
So don't fall for this trap of
people are hardcore or people
are casual.
Just focus who it is that
you're trying to serve, and try
to understand them better.
The people I'm trying to
serve for "Alphabear 2"
are people who like word
games and cute things.
And those people happen
to like competition also,
in many cases.
I don't call them casuals.
And this, by the way, is
a great example of this.
It's one of the few
screenshots I have in here.
This is a game
called "Love Nikki,"
which was hugely,
hugely inspiring
to the people in our studio.
Because a lot of developers who
we respect and designers who we
respect were telling us you
cannot make a complex RPG
for your target market.
You just can't, it won't work.
You need to keep
it super simple.
It needs to be easy to
learn, hard to master.
I'm sure you've heard
that a million times.
It's just got to be easy
learn, hard to master.
And you have to go
with the "Candy Crush"
style of monetization.
You can't do anything
more than that.
You want to do puzzle and
dragon for casual gamers?
You're crazy.
This game, for those of you
who aren't familiar with it,
is a game about acquiring
clothing and then having
dress battles.
Like, that's what you do.
You have your little
dress-up battles.
I cannot tell you how
amazing this game is to me.
It is so complicated.
There are so many
currencies, and affinities,
and various things that
play into whether you're
going to succeed in a battle.
And this game is played,
as far as I know--
I don't have all the
details because they're not
made public.
But as far as I
know, the audience
is overwhelmingly female, pretty
broad in terms of age range.
And it makes a ton of money.
It doesn't make any
sense if you follow
the whole stereotypes of
what a casual gamer is
willing to tolerate.
It makes no sense whatsoever.
But this game is
really successful.
And the fact that
it was successful
gave us the courage to make a
fairly complicated meta-game
in "Alphabear 2."
I don't know if
we would have been
willing to if we didn't know
something like this existed.
So anyway, take that
for what it's worth.
Another misconception--
there's a few lucky developers
who can rely on primo featuring
by Apple and Google to succeed.
They don't really need
anything else aside
from making their good game.
That's no longer true either.
It used to be true.
And I'm speaking
from experience.
We've been very
lucky as a developer.
Everything we've ever made has
gotten a really great feature
by at least Apple or
Google, and oftentimes both.
But to put this in perspective,
when "Alphabear 1" came out
not that long ago, we got
in the first few weeks
after it was out a
million downloads.
And that was with one
really good feature
and one OK feature.
When "Bushido Bear" came out,
same thing, over a million
downloads in the
first few weeks.
When "Alphabear
2" came out, which
was just a couple of months
ago, we got better support
in terms of overall support.
Both platforms supported
us very strongly,
which isn't always the case.
And yet we only got a few
hundred thousand downloads
in the same time period.
That's with the best feature
we could have asked for.
We literally could not
have asked for any better
from either side.
It's just the
nature of the beast.
Things have changed.
The market is more
competitive now.
Google Play and the
App Store themselves
have fundamentally changed
in a few different ways.
And you basically cannot rely
on features to be a success
anymore.
You have to, at the
end of the day--
and I think Mike was talking
about this earlier on his
panel--
you have to have an LTV that
enables you to play the user
acquisition game.
You have to be making at least
$0.50-$1 per user on average.
And the number depends on
the nature of your audience,
and the cost of acquisition
for users in that audience.
But the bottom line
is, if you're not
making a decent amount
of money per user,
you're going to fall flat.
This has been a very
hard realization for us.
As a company, we've always
been really, really focused
on just trying to make
the best game we can
and not worrying too
much about the money,
and then hoping that
we'll be rewarded for it.
And that doesn't work anymore.
So basically, almost all of
our effort now on "Alphabear 2"
is going into trying to raise
up the LTV of our users, which
is not, to be perfectly
honest, the most fun
part of game development,
at least not for us.
But it's that or die.
And so we're trying
to figure out
how can we do that kind
of work and still enjoy
what we do for a living.
And there are some
creative ways to do it.
So in "Alphabear
2," for example,
you can get rewards
for watching ads
in this mode called TV Time.
And when you watch those ads,
your avatar and his companion,
Doc Bear, are sitting there.
And they literally crap all over
the ads that you're watching.
They have like critical
commentary about it.
And that made me feel better.
I almost don't care
if our users like it,
although they do, by the way.
It made me feel better about it.
So whatever it takes.
Figure out what makes you feel
better about monetization,
and then take it
super, super seriously.
Because if you don't,
you're going to fall flat.
So another misconception--
with compelling enough content
and IP, you can sell
content packs to succeed,
and that's really
all you need to sell.
That's mostly false too.
So I'm sure all of you
guys remember "Mario Run."
It's like oh, Mario is
finally coming to mobile!
My god, it's going to
be an enormous success.
How can it not be
an enormous success?
It wasn't an enormous
success, it turns out.
Or at least it wasn't
a big enough success
that Nintendo was willing to
do something like that again.
It's really hard,
it turns out, to get
people to pay just for what
they see as a content pack.
I don't fully understand why, to
be completely honest with you.
I have not spent enough
time thinking about it
to really understand it.
But it's not the most
successful monetization scheme.
It's one of the
easiest ones, which
is why it's so tempting
for developers to do it.
It's like, oh sure,
like I'll make
300 more levels, which
I can have a content
team do in a month or two.
And then I'll put them
out there for 10 bucks.
Because it's so straightforward,
it's very tempting.
It doesn't tend to work.
There are exceptions
again, that prove the rule.
But it doesn't tend to be
the most successful model,
so be wary of this one.
Another misconception-- players
will only tolerate opt-in ads.
This is, by the
way, a misconception
that I had until
very, very recently.
It's false, but it's
false in the same way
a lot of things I've been
talking about are false.
It's false depending
on your audience.
There are some
audiences for which
this is almost certainly true.
My guess is that if you tried
to make a game like "Fortnite,"
and you put enforced
interstitials into it
that you would fail miserably.
Because my guess is since
"Fortnite" users are not
accustomed to that, they
would be furious with you.
They'd be like, why am I going
to play this piece of crap that
forces me to watch ads
when I go play "Fortnite?"
But on the other hand, if you're
trying to make a word game,
like I was with "Alphabear
2--" well, let's go
look at what the number
one word game is.
The number one word
game on Google Play
currently is a game
called "Wordscapes."
Oh, interesting.
After almost every level, it's
making me watch a video ad.
What the heck?
And there's still number one.
Apparently, they
have a great rating
and they're making good money.
So even though I knew that,
I couldn't believe it.
I just could not
internalize the fact
that forced interstitials
would be OK.
Because I personally
dislike them so much.
And so we launched without them.
We didn't have them in the game.
And then we were disappointed
after a ton of work
on rewarded video-- we
spent weeks and weeks trying
to make our rewarded
video like the "TV Time"
thing that I mentioned earlier.
We spent weeks and weeks
trying to make that compelling
and it didn't really work out.
We had some views,
but not nearly as many
as we needed to survive.
So finally, some friends of
mine hit me over the head
hard enough.
And they were like,
you really need
to try to force interstitials.
And you're like, fine, fine, OK.
But even then, we were
so worried about it
that we did an A/B test.
We weren't willing to
just put them in the game.
So we had some users in the
A/B test seeing interstitials
after basically every
game, and some users
seeing them very rarely.
So now I can tell you factually,
because I A/B tested it,
there was zero
difference in retention.
Like literally, zero.
None.
The people who saw
them all the time
retain just as
well as the people
who didn't barely see them.
And then interestingly
enough, we
didn't have a
control group where
you didn't get forced
interstitials at all, just
because we were worried about
dividing up our audience too
much.
But we compared our
pre-test retention
to our post-test retention.
At most, maybe we lost like
half a percent retention.
Like, it was meaningless
So long story short, for
our audience, at least,
forced interstitials
were completely fine,
and helped us make
a lot more money.
Please don't leave
this lecture and think
David Edery said put forced
interstitials in every game.
Absolutely not.
Figure out if your
audience is OK with them.
And then the next question is--
even then, maybe you
don't want to do it.
Maybe you can find some other
way to make money without them.
But if you can't, if
you end up in the boat
we were in, where we were like,
crap, no one's watching our ads
and we already spent weeks
working on this, maybe.
Some other tips-- moving
on from misconceptions.
This is just a brief one.
It doesn't really
actually have that much
to do with free-to-play.
But I really want to mention
it, cause it's that important.
We use a service called
Play TestCloud, which
is a place where we
can upload an APK.
And then we'll get a video back
of the person playing our game.
And we can see where
they're touching it.
And they actually
speak what they're
thinking as they're doing it.
So if they get
confused, they're like,
I'm confused right
now, what's going on?
And you can know exactly
what's going on in their head.
It's a godsend.
It's so unbelievably useful.
I don't know if you
have other ways.
Like if you by some miracle have
access to a great playtest lab,
great.
I mean, obviously, use that.
And of course I do
things all the time.
Even with stuff like
this, I'll go to neighbors
and watch them play
and things like that.
But I cannot tell
you how useful it is.
Particularly in how
hyper-competitive the
free-to-play market is
today, your first 30
minutes to 60
minutes of game play
have to basically be flawless.
Because that's what
you're competing against.
You're competing
against companies
that have flawless 60-minute
experiences, because they have
infinite money and can do that.
They can tune and tune and tune.
And I don't know
of any other way
to get there aside from
using a service like this
for a company like ours.
I mean, we don't
even have an office.
I don't have anywhere to invite
people to do play testing,
so this thing is
a godsend for us.
We will constantly be surprised
by what people are confused by.
I mean, "Alphabear
2" was not all that
different in the first 30
minutes from "Alphabear 1."
And we were still
shocked at the number
of things in
"Alphabear 2's" first
60 minutes that caused people
to freak out and get totally
confused.
So anyway, I highly
recommend checking it out
if you don't already have
a play testing solution.
The second thing-- and this is
more specifically free-to-play.
I'm back to being on topic.
Offerwalls can be
surprisingly effective.
So I don't know about you guys--
of course, an offerwall
is the like, hey.
It pops up a list of games.
You download them, you get
some free coins in my game.
My first experience
with offerwalls
was several years ago.
I thought they sucked.
They had all kinds of
technical problems.
They tended not to work well.
They didn't make me
all that much money.
It wasn't worth the headache.
So I kind of had this idea
that offerwalls were terrible.
And then I had a couple of
friends with "Alphabear 2"
tell me, look, they've gotten
much better, you should try it.
And I was like, OK,
fine, twist my arm.
And so we spent like
six weeks or whatever--
I don't even remember
the amount of time.
It was probably more than that--
trying to make our
rewarded video awesome.
And we put this in
in like two days.
And we put no effort into
making it compelling.
We buried it in the store
menu, and that was that.
And it makes as much money
as the rewarded video
does, even though I put no
effort into it whatsoever.
Which is kind of both
wonderful and horrible.
But you know, that's
game development.
So if you have written off
offerwalls like we did,
you might want to
check them out.
They can actually make a
decent amount of money.
And they don't seem to be
as sucky as they used to.
And then lastly-- and this
is the most important tip
I'll give you--
is that I think it's vital that
if you're planning on borrowing
elements from the meta-game
of a free-to-play game
that you've been
inspired by, you
have to play it for
months before you do that.
I've actually talked
to a bunch of--
I have some friends
who are consultants.
Like for a living,
they just give advice
to other people on
free-to-play game design.
And several of them
have told me this
is one of the number
one mistakes they
see their customers make,
which is why I wanted
to close my lecture with this.
I've noticed this myself too.
You'll have someone who'll
be like oh, yeah, I played--
I'll mention again that
I've actually played a lot
and really enjoy "Star
Wars, Galaxy of Heroes."
I played it for a week.
I thought it was awesome.
I really like what
they do with--
whatever, fill in the blank.
We're going to put
that in our game.
Well, "Star Wars,
Galaxy of Heroes"
is a game that
evolves tremendously
over months of play.
If you've been
playing it for a week,
you have literally no
idea what you're doing.
You cannot copy that
game effectively.
You cannot copy a piece
of it effectively.
You may, for example,
see where it's like,
oh, OK, there's three places
in the game where they
sell things for hard currency.
That must be where they
get all their revenue.
Maybe.
Or maybe those three
things are actually not
really that big a deal.
Maybe there's a fourth thing
coming four weeks from now
that you haven't
even unlocked yet
and it's actually where
the majority of the revenue
comes from.
But you don't know
because you haven't gotten
to that point in the meta yet.
This is less of an issue
for the more simple games
out there, like the
hyper-casual stuff
that tends to be
pretty straightforward.
But particularly, for things
that have a fairly complicated
meta-game, like "Love
Nikki," for example,
that I was mentioning
earlier, you just can't.
You absolutely
can't play that game
for less than several
months if you really
want to deeply understand it.
It does not matter
how smart you are.
I work with some
really smart people.
A lot of them were
super confused
by how these games made
money until they played them
for six months.
You have to do this.
Please, if nothing else you
remember from this lecture,
remember this.
And the thing is that I've
heard a lot of people say,
when I tell them these
kinds of things--
but I don't like it enough
to play it for that long.
Then it's like, why are you
making a game like that then?
What are you thinking?
Don't make something that
you dislike so much that you
can't bear playing it.
That doesn't make any sense.
You're not going to
do a good job, right?
So seriously,
either decide you're
going to find a way to like
it or move on and do something
else.
But that is the worst
excuse I've ever
heard for doing a half-assed
job of copying a feature out
of some other game.
And I hear it a lot, actually.
And by the way, the
reason I included
these screenshots is because
this is just showing the event
system from "Alphabear 2."
The screenshot that says "live
to eat" is basically the entry.
That's the sort of entry
portal to one of our events.
And then the screenshot
on the right is a bundle.
And it's a bundle designed to
help you succeed in that event.
That is something
that I was directly
inspired by the way they
monetize events in "Star
Wars, Galaxy of Heroes."
It's been hugely
successful for us.
We've made quite a lot of money
with this specific feature.
I don't think I
would have thought
of the specific implementation
without having played
"Star Wars Galaxies" for--
I mean, I've been playing at
this point for over a year.
But I had to play
it for many months
to really put that together.
So it's worked out
very well for us.
I'm pretty confident
that I would
have screwed the pooch
on this if I had only
played the game for a week.
Yeah.
And I think that's it.
Thank you very much, guys.